meantime long lines of cars took over
samboy stadium again today as hundreds
showed up for cobit testing tonight
though an improvement compared to last
madison kimbrough joining us now live
from that site with the changes made by
the county madison
yeah denise there's not a lot going on
right now but earlier it was very busy
here and tonight went a lot better for
drivers as having a designated line with
police monitoring it made all the
difference i've been here since 11 30
and the line goes all the way into the
houses four blocks over drive through
covet 19 testing continued monday night
at sam boyd stadium for the second day
in a row and people in line pleased with
how it went it seems like it's flowing
really smoothly there's not a lot of
like just stopping we pre-registered so
that kind of took a lot of the time off
of it so that was nice i think it's
pretty organized yesterday was a little
bit different around 9 30. i live around
here in the same neighborhood a bit
different indeed as opening day on
sunday created a massive traffic jam
causing a lot of frustration among
drivers the county recognizing that and
providing police to monitor the lines
monday traffic was narrowed down to a
single entry lane along broadbent from
the south and message boards were placed
at key locations to let motorists know
where to access testing so far so good i
came in about 4 10 so it's moving pretty
good 300 coveted 19 vaccines and 1200
tests are made available each night on a
first come first serve basis depending
on daily supplies and staffing and on
sunday the county was able to administer
over 2 000 tests reaching 400 tests an
hour tester self swab pcr tests and
results take about 72 hours to process
the county encourages those who plan on
testing to register and create an
account online ahead of time to cut down
on wait times again the sam boyd
location is going to be open sunday
through thursday that's 5 30 to 10 30
p.m reporting live from sam boyd madison
kimbrough live local now